>> Stan: NOT AT ALL.
THEY COME TO THIS GAME THEY'RE
19-13 WHEN HE PLAYS AND 11-2
WHEN HE DOESN'T.
THAT'S INCREDIBLE, ESPECIALLY
FOR A GUY THAT'S HAVING THIS
KIND OF YEAR.
>> Brian: BRADLEY FOULS MORANT.
THEY GET TIED UP.
NOW GETTING INTO IT ON THE
FLOOR.
>> Stan: STEVEN ADAMS LITERALLY
LIFTED UP TONY BRADLEY WHO IS
NOT A SMALL GUY.
HE LITERALLY JUST LIFTED HIM UP
AND CARRIED HIM AWAY FROM JA
MORANT.
>> Brian: TONY BRADLEY IS 6'7",
220.
ADAMS JUST HOISTS HIM.
>> Stan: I THINK JA MORANT, HE
GOT FOULED.
HE SEEMED TO BE MORE THE
INSTIGATOR IN THE BATTLE.
BUT STEVEN ADAMS, ALWAYS GOING
TO PROTECT HIS TEAMMATES.
HE DID SO HERE.
BRADLEY WOULDN'T LET GO, EVEN
AFTER MORANT PUSHED THE BALL IN
HIS FACE.
STEVEN ADAMS JUST SAID, ALL
RIGHT, HERE, LET ME TAKE YOU
OVER HERE WITH ME.
>> Brian: I THINK MORANT TOOK
EXCEPTION TO WHERE BRADLEY'S
KNEE WAS DIRECTED, RIGHT THERE.
>> Stan: IT WILL BE INTERESTING
HOW THEY